Carissa another victory for you but this
one I mean you came back from a very
difficult position I have to say out of
the opening and we discussed a bit after
you said that this move Knight to D2 was
not in your preparation or maybe you
missed something you forgot something
what was it um yeah so she's only ever
played C takes D4 actually
um she's had like a quite a few games in
at this point in this place so yeah C
takes G4 and so most of my prep like
most of me memorizing my prep was like
in this line and some deviations from it
and so I wasn't expecting Queen C7
um but you know I had this cover too and
I had D5 yeah normal move yes and I
believe here after Knight V6 I was
supposed to play Bishop E3
um where a waitress has like a pretty
comfortable position perhaps and then 92
is coming and everything works out so
what's the difference Carissa why why is
Bishop 3 so much better yes I think
after Knight d2c4 my Bishops kind of
forced onto B2
and it just kind of sucks there uh the
bishop should not be on B2 it's like
Locked In by its own Pawn
um in Blacks the one with more control
on the queen side
um
and so kind of at this point I was like
hmm screwed something up you weren't
really happy with your position yeah and
allowing this uh Knight H5 thing wasn't
great either okay but
I was hoping for some sort of play with
like the week
C4 Pawn
um
and we did some shuffling pieces around
so many tricked her
um
and you know this position is kind of
like the same it's 10 moves ago right
not that much has happened a lot of
shuffling but one thing that was
happening is Gracie was getting lower
and lower on time and you were still
keeping up pace definitely maintaining
your time Advantage was that part of the
strategy
um try to get her down to her last few
minutes yeah I wasn't really sure how
she was as like a player now she thinks
a lot or she's kind of more chill with
it
um but once we got to around this point
she had like you know 20 minutes left
and I was feeling pretty good about the
situation and I felt that maybe it could
be time to start looking at some breaks
create something in the position and
that's
well she actually helped you with this
move Rook to ba to create those breaks
in the position because finally the C4
Pawn
is not only hanging but is being lost
yeah
um what do you think she missed
I think she just missed that it was
hanging all together
um and she was just trying to play
quickly to make it to 40 moves and that
just ended up being a blunder yeah and
you found this nice move night to be to
if you go Knight to D2 she still has
some compensation after Bishop to H6 but
he played it quite quickly and I have to
say after this it was all you in this
game nice break
Chris a good victory for you very
important Victory especially before uh
the break Alice Drew her game now you
only have a point behind her tell us a
bit about this Dynamic right now in
tournament how do you see it um I mean
I'm pretty disappointed with my results
so far I had like a really bad game
yesterday
um this one also wasn't ideal but I'm
hoping with the rest day I kind of can
collect myself
and also as for the tournament standings
I think it's still anyone's game
um you know as long as I'm not trailing
by too far and I can sort of keep Pace
until we play you know everything's
still in my hands and so I feel pretty
good about that what are you going to do
during the rest day to ease your mind
maybe get some walks in what's the plan
um I don't know I'm probably just going
to
hang out with some friends
in the tournament
um spend some time with my dad just
relax a bit so we have to get back into
the grind
congratulations for uh your Victory
Carissa guys any questions no just our
congrat congratulations improve your
play and uh well enjoy enjoy the
experience of the of the girls
Championship Carissa thank you
absolutely